MALE SPEAKER: I want to
really quickly introduced
Joe Hall, which is
a total pleasure.
Although last minute
duties, so apologies
for not being over rehearsed.
I've known Joe for a long time.
We were in grad school
together at Berkeley.
While I was in law
school, Joe was there
getting his Ph.D. He was
actually first prominent,
in my life and
around the country,
for working on voting systems,
electronic and online voting
systems, and also
voting machines
and the security around them.
And I think that was the
focus of your dissertation.
Right?
JOE HALL: Oh, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
so I worked on that,
and an election season couldn't
go without Joe appearing
on every various media
outlet talking about it.
And then he's, of course,
moved on from that
into a broader range of work.
He was a post-doc
fellow at Princeton
with Ed Felten, who is
no stranger to policy
and technology issues,
and also worked
with Helen Nissenbaum at NYU.
And in the last year, has
come down to Washington DC,
has joined the
beast, and now works
at the Center for
Democracy and Technology.
He's their first ever-- is that
right? --chief technologist.
JOE HALL: Yeah.
Well, we had a chief
computer scientist before me,
but I didn't feel comfortable.
MALE SPEAKER: Right, and
computer scientist, too small
of a title for Joe
Hall, who's the Chief
Technologist at the Center
for Democracy and Technology,
a fantastic online civil
liberties organization
and advocacy group.
And also, just because at Google
we love our well roundedness,
in addition to all the
other things that he's done,
Joe has also been a pastry chef.
He has been a ranch
hand, and he's also
instructed yoga,
been a life guard,
and a riflery instructor
for a youth camp.
By the way, if the
apocalypse occurs,
I want this guy on my side.
And with that, I want to pass
it over to Joe Hall for a talk
and, hopefully, some
time for questions.
If you have questions, please
save them until the end.
And also, if you are
and GBC, please leave it
muted to avoid further
technology disruption.
Thank you so much.
Joe.
JOE HALL: Thank you, sir.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
JOE HALL: Oh.
So I have quite a slide
deck here for you.
I think I'm going to try
and go for 40 minutes,
and I may skip over some things.
And if I skip over
something that's
really true and dear to
your heart for some reason,
let me know, and we'll
go back during Q&A.
But I want to make sure
there's plenty of time
for Q&A. Q&A will
not be recorded,
so feel free to do whatever
you want to do during Q&A.
[LAUGHTER]
JOE HALL: So what I want to
talk about here is tech policy,
and specifically, I've
been in DC for a year
now after leaving academia.
And it's been a crazy
year, man, and I just
want to give you a
flavor for how crazy it's
been for what's going on.
And what I want to do
is talk a little bit
about the FBI and
backdoors, the NSA and what
we call the
cryptapocalypse, and then
novel technologies like drones.
And I am the chief
technologist at the CDT,
and we are hiring, by the
way, not that any of you
should leave wonderful
jobs at Google.
But please, let
your friends know
that might be interested
in this kind of stuff.
Quick outline, so I got tell
you a little bit about who I am.
We'll do some of that.
What is CDT?
Some of you may have
never heard of us.
We're pretty low profile kind of
an organization and what I do.
And then talking about how does
tech policy work inside DC?
How does anything about
technology get done?
Is it as frustrating
as you may think
it is here in Silicon Valley?
And then walk through some of
these specific case studies.
So who am I?
Well, I have a background
in hard sciences.
I did my undergrad at
Northern Arizona University
in Flagstaff, Arizona, where I
modeled planetary atmospheres,
which is a whole lot of fun.
And we actually-- oops.
Oh, I see what's going on.
We actually found clouds
on a moon of Saturn,
called Titan, that has
sort of a methane cycle,
just like the Earth has a water
cycle with oceans and rain.
And on Titan, they actually have
that, but with something else.
It's very, very cold.
Anyway, that's just
to give you an idea
of some of the stuff I've done.
I tend to tell people I hacked
voting machines for my Ph.D.
It was much more
complicated than that.
We were on the policy
side of this stuff.
We were funded by an enormous
grant by NSF, a $10 million
grant for five years,
to basically think about
how do we make these black
boxes a little more trustworthy.
And we were invited,
as you can see,
we were invited to
hack voting machines
for the state of California.
This is our current Secretary
of State Debra Bowen.
A lot of interesting
people here,
Matt Blaise, Alex
Halderman, Dierdre Mulligan,
Ping Ye, who is a Googler.
I don't know if anyone
else here is a Googler.
Many of them have been interns.
And you can see right
here, when we did it
for Ohio on the right,
this is resetting
all the administrative passwords
on this voting machine using
a magnet and a
palm pilot we just
had sort of sitting around.
Yeah, it's that bad,
and it's actually
kind of a little bit worse
than that these days.
The stuff that I
work on regularly
involves consumer privacy,
health technology,
national security,
cyber security,
and technical standard setting.
I still do some e-voting
and some space policy stuff.
You can kind of
think of me-- this
is why I call myself
a technologist.
I'm sort of half a lawyer and
a half a computer scientist,
but my degree is from a
school of information,
so it's like a Ph.D. in
information of all things.
But I say that because
this is my Ph.D. committee.
Pam Samuelson was my
Ph.D. adviser on the left,
and Dierdre Mulligan was my
grant supervisor next to her,
and those two were
law professors.
And then David
Wagner at Berkeley
was sort of a
computer scientist,
very, very well respected
computer security guy,
the guy I often say what
would David Wagner do
when I do things.
I may not do that thing, but
I at least ask that question.
And then [INAUDIBLE]
Cheshire on the far right,
who does social psychology.
So what is CDT?
The Center for
Democracy and Technology
is a nonprofit think tank.
We're sort of half think
tank, half advocacy outfit.
We're a bunch of nerds,
and we do a whole lot
of actual advocacy work in DC.
We're about 20 years old.
We used to actually be EFF's DC
office, the Electronic Frontier
Foundation's DC office.
There is a little bit of
a falling out of sorts,
and we broke off
about 20 years ago.
I can talk about that.
What's our support come from?
Largely foundations
and corporate
support, so not half and half.
It's much more
complicated than that.
You can go to cdt.org financial
and add it up yourself
if you want to figure
these things out.
But this sort of underlines
our principles, which
involve empowering people
with digital technology
and the internet, and
this means that we
want to have things that
are forward looking,
very progressive types of
collaborative solutions,
and tangible pragmatic
policy outcomes.
And this often involves making
sure we bring businesses
into the conversation.
We get a lot of flack for
taking corporate money,
but at the same time, we think
that it's really a good idea.
The internet doesn't just
exist without the economic case
for doing things
on the internet,
and we think it's really
important to make sure
that's done responsibly and
that things don't chill that.
And a lot of what we
do is never public,
which people-- it's very hard
to fund things with grant
money, foundation money,
when a lot of what you do
is just not public.
When it comes down to face
to face meetings and stuff
like that, you may not
be able to say here's
a big press release,
because it may
deep six entire
relationships you have.
It's important to
think a little bit
about what technology policy is.
The basic way to say
it is it's the rules
that we set about technology,
and it's not just laws.
If you have two small kids
arguing over a very large piece
of cake, you can set up
a really easy experiment
because they both have the
interest of getting the most
cake, where one cuts and
the other gets to choose it.
And that is essentially
aligning incentives
to get the best outcome,
the outcome being both kids
are somewhat convinced
that they're happy,
and they participated
in the process,
so they know what's going on.
But it's not just sort
of social outcomes.
It's also technical, so to
what extent do the things
we do result in better
things happening,
better technology being
able to exist and thriving.
And economic interests,
to what extent
does it help the country,
and other countries,
sort of build
innovative products
and employ people
and things like that?
This can mean that certain
things are prohibited
when you make rules
about technology,
and if you're a
technologist-- I don't
know how many of you in the room
are, but maybe a lot of you.
Technologists can often be
frustrated when someone tells
them, oh, you can't do
that, and so for example,
you cannot currently take
satellite imagery that is lower
than about 50 centimeter
resolution, at least in the US.
If you're a US company,
you cannot put a satellite
in the air and then sell
the products that come out
the other end.
That means you guys at
Google can't actually
use products that
have things that
are lower than that resolution.
There's currently a
company, Globalize,
currently petitioning
US government
to be able to launch a
satellite that would do that,
and they're trying
to make the case,
look, there's not
a lot more that's
going to be able to--
you know, 25 centimeter
resolution doesn't
mean you're going
to be seeing faces
and things that
might be problematic from
a privacies prospective.
Or particular
installations, that's
not going to make
a big difference.
Now, we should
also mention we're
going to be able to start doing
things on the consumer end
really soon that can be kind
of scary, print gun parts,
print molecules like Sarin gas.
How do you control that when
it's a very cheap consumer
technology?
Can you control that?
Do you have to resort to more
informal methods of control,
like norms, "Don't do
Sarin gas," to your kids?
I don't know.
You also can't do
certain things.
Like for example, you can
go buy a pager right now,
hack it, and eavesdrop on all
the pager traffic around you,
very similar to plugging
into an ethernet port.
If you have the right
technical capabilities,
you can read a lot of
traffic that's flying around,
and your cellphone
broadcasts stuff, too.
You can't just do those
things, and maybe I'm
preaching to the choir,
just because it's
technically possible.
There's reasons
we have rules that
make those things hard to do,
or at least to disincentivize
people doing that by
punishing them later.
So in DC specifically-- and if
you've been in DC for a while,
you sort of know
how this works, so
feel free to go to sleep for
about five or 10 minutes.
There's various sort of
constituencies and stakeholders
that we work with
to get things done.
Congress is obviously
a big one, lately
not passing laws so much,
but preventing bad laws
from being passed.
In Congress, there's
all these support staff
called staffers,
legislative councils,
various types of people.
They're so key to talk with
when you're in DC in the sense
that they're often the ones
that, not only do you have
to explain very
complicated topics to,
but you have to
explain them in a way
that they can then explain
them to their bosses.
So it's not just, oh, I get it.
It's about, no, look,
this is exactly what
you need to be able to
say your boss in order
for them to have a
hope of understanding
what we're talking about.
You do that sometimes
through briefings,
so you'll go in and talk
to a single staffer,
or a whole bunch of them,
or maybe a whole room
like this full of staffers, and
it's like pedagogy in a sense.
You're teaching them something.
You're trying to show
them your way of view.
But it's people who have
maybe 30 minutes between one
high powered negotiating meaning
where they're doing something
on nuclear waste,
and something else
where they may be trying to
get to different kinds of visas
for immigrant
workers to come in.
We do end up-- people
will hand us bills
and say what do you
think about this a law
that we haven't
released yet, and we
have to say it doesn't makes
sense for us to look at that.
Or should we throw
it in the trash?
Because the second you
start working with people
and saying this is how
the law should work,
it becomes lobbying.
When you start to work with the
executive agencies or Congress
about how laws should look
and how they should pass,
and how this one's
bad, or you really
should add a feature like that
to it, you're doing lobbying.
And we are not
registered lobbyists,
so we have to, by law,
keep it to about 20%
of our total
resource allocation,
to be technical about it.
The very, very high
profile and valuable way
to work with Congress
is through testimony.
So we are often, at CDT,
asked to come in and testify
because a number of us have
expertise in certain areas.
But more often, we say,
look, you don't want us.
You want someone else.
You want Susan
Landau, for example.
You want Ed Felten.
You want Ave Rubin.
You want whoever
it is, Kevin Fu.
You want some of these
people to come in and talk
to you about these things.
That is a big goal of
us, in that process,
is to make it really
plug and play,
to sort of have experts
come in and, like I
was telling Will
over lunch, and Troy,
that you don't want to have
to worry about printing
50 copies of some
written testimony, which
is what they ask you do.
Bring 50 copies
of the things you
just spent two days of
your time writing with you,
and you're like, wait,
where am I going to do that?
How am I going to do that?
That sucks.
It's heavy.
What?
So we do that, and we also
will do things like look
at the testimony
and say that's going
to trigger someone's other
policy agenda on this side.
They may have a dog in the
fight on this other issue.
So we try and sort of make it to
where experts want to come back
and do this again.
And that's hard to do
because, sometimes, people
are like I'm never setting
foot back in Washington DC
after the grilling I got
by that Congress member.
And if that's the
case, that's too bad,
but we hope to make sure that we
have people come in regularly.
We do work with the
executive branch quite a bit,
so this includes the White
House and a slew of agencies.
This is sort of like
the alphabet soup slide,
and there's some--
unfortunately,
this is not a technical
alphabet soup,
and so it's not nearly
fun as some of the ones
later, where I'll talk
about technical stuff.
But the White House has various
sort of arms that we work with.
NSS for the National
Security Staff,
which has been a huge
challenge lately.
There's just a
whole lot going on,
and we'll talk a lot
about that later.
OSTP, the Office of Science
and Technology Policy.
We actually have, at least at
the National Security Staff,
we have a former
CDT employee who's
the head of the civil liberties
and privacy part of that,
and so he's extremely
busy these days.
And USTR, the US
Trade Representative,
how do we work with
other countries,
and how do we negotiate certain
kinds of instruments that
make sure that the US
is on equal footing
with other countries where
the things we care about
are embodied in what we do?
And that can be a challenge
because, on the copyright side,
the US tend to be
very, very aggro about,
very, very aggressive
about things.
Whereas what we want
to see is like it's
very hard to use IETF
standards in Europe
because they favor
government developed
standards, not open consensus
kinds of flavors and standards.
In terms of agencies,
there's just a ton of them.
Department of Commerce
is pretty big,
and we work a lot of
them in order to say here
are the incentives
involved in what we do.
The NTIA, the National
Telecommunications
and Information Administration,
is the White House's advisors
in terms of internet
policy, and so
if you can convince some of
them to care about your issue,
then you're doing a good job.
And again, one of the CDT's
former staffers, John Morris,
is at NTIA.
And NIST is what I've
been doing a lot lately.
National Institute of
Standards and Technology
makes all sorts of standards
about cryptography,
computer security, cyber
security, stuff like that.
And this is all to say there's
a bunch of them, Federal Trade
Commission, Federal
Communication
Commission, Health
and Human Services,
the FDA, which is a part of
the Health and Human Services
in terms of medical
device rules,
Department of
Transportation is when
it comes to drones, the Federal
Aviation Administration.
The thing that I want
to get across here
is, with regulatory
proceedings--
so those are things like RFIs,
requests for information;
ANPRMs, and advanced notice
of proposed rulemaking;
NPRMs, notice of
proposed rulemaking.
These are extremely important
for people to be involved with.
In your private capacity if you
can, but it's very important
to hear from industry
and trade associations,
blah, blah, blah,
whatever you want.
RFIs are a way, for an
agency, of saying, look,
we have no clue
what's going on here.
We need some input.
Please, come to us and
write a short little paper
and tell us what's going on.
ANPRMs, advance notice
of proposed rulemaking,
says there's a law
that says we have
to write a rule
about some subject.
We're thinking about
writing it like this.
We don't know if that's
the right way to do it.
Please, come in and let and
let us know if that's right.
And then NPRM is like, OK,
here's what we're going to do.
Because, I should have
said this earlier,
but when laws get
passed in Congress,
they're typically
very, very high level.
They're typically
go do x, y, or z,
and then you have to
actually operationalize that.
You have to go and write the
specific rules down and get
them passed, such
that that works.
So like for example,
healthcare.gov, there
are a ton of really
crazy thousands
of pages of rules that talk
about how the exchanges work,
how things are supposed to work.
There's not a lot of information
about the technical stuff
in this, which is kind of a
pain in the butt for those of us
who need to talk to the
press or other people
about why it's sort of
failing so amazingly.
And I'm not talking about here.
We can talk about
in Q&A. There's just
some really horrible
things going on.
We also participate in
workshops and proceedings,
so I'm going to be speaking
at a Federal Trade Commission
workshop on the Internet
of Things, which
is a-- I guess it's been
a-- I was going to say it's
a marketing term, but it's
been around for a long time.
So you can't just sort
of write off like that.
But I'm talking about
telehealth stuff on the 19th,
and we'll see what happens.
It should be pretty interesting.
We don't do a lot of court
stuff, like litigation.
We very rarely do that.
I think the last time we
did it was something called
Reno versus ACLU,
which makes sure
that-- it's about
intermediary liability.
This is why YouTube can have
people come and put things
up and not get in trouble
themselves for things
that people put up.
We do file as amici,
so amicus briefs.
That basically means a
friend of the court brief,
where we come in and we're
not a party to the matter,
but we want to say, look,
these guys are duking it out.
But we think you really need
to care about something else
that neither of them are
going to tell you about,
or they're not going to
value as much as we do,
like the public
interest for example.
But we do, in litigation,
support people or partners
that do litigate and
are all over the place,
like the Electronic Frontier
Foundation, the ACLU
chapters in every
state, public knowledge.
There's a lot of copyright and
intellectual property stuff.
Press, so this is
the last way that we
work a lot with people in DC.
Press is amazingly important
and really effective
when you do it well, and man,
I have a lot of challenges
with doing press well.
I was on Glenn Beck's-- Glenn
Beck has a cable news network,
or cable network, called
the Blaze apparently.
I didn't know this.
But I was on it,
and they really are
on Obama's ass about
the whole NSA thing,
and they wanted to come in
and someone to criticize it
and say why are they
doing all these things?
And we're like, oh, happy
to come and criticize it.
We think it's wrong.
It's not a partisan
thing at all.
It's that you shouldn't
collect that much stuff.
But the disconcerting
part about this
is that when I want to be
doing a technical analysis
or writing a paper or
interfacing with someone to get
something done, it can be
like half of my day some days.
Especially if there's a
Snowden revelation lately,
I have to clear things for
about a day and a half,
and it's just a
pain in the butt.
But you've got to do
it, or they'll never
come again, which is
not what you want.
But it's really
important because you
have this core part of
what people like me do,
which is translation.
I often have to talk to
technical people about the law,
like yeah, you did that.
You can't do that.
Here's why you can't do that.
Or talk to lawyers
about technology.
Here's how that
thing, IPv6, works.
Here's why you
should care about it.
Here's how you want to change
what you're talking about
and how your writing about.
It can be a big
challenge, and what
I mean by that-- so
for example, here
is a article from
the other day, where
I was quote talking
about healthcare.gov.
And the quote comes out,
the beginning-- and there's
like eight other people
quoted in this article.
But the first quote
and the second one,
if you can't read it, it
says "Some of these things
are really amateur hour.
This might just be an
error, but you could not
pass an undergraduate
computer science
class by making these mistakes."
And it's very
aggressive, and CDT
doesn't tend to want to
come off that aggressive.
But at the same time,
we were seeing things
like refer headers leaked to
Pingdom and doubleclick.net,
and these refer headers had
user names and password reset
codes in them.
And it's this long URL with all
these ampersand encoded things,
and we're just like I don't
know what any of that crap is,
but that is bad, bad, bad.
That would be a fail on
a web security class.
And then at the very
end, the problem
is even when you get
quoted, sometimes, they
don't get the quote
right, and you sort of
have to live with it.
So at the very
end, it says, "When
it comes to functionality,
the last thing you think about
is security."
Being experienced in
this kind of thing,
what I tried to get
across was people
are trying to make things work.
They don't think
about the adversaries.
about ways that people
could mess with your
stuff, and that's
what I tried to get across.
But it makes it look
like I'm saying, oh,
securities the
last thing you do.
But I did follow up
there by saying, look,
you need to think about it.
It's so deeply ingrained that
you can't just add it on later.
This is something that we've
learned about over and over
again from failures.
You can't add it on later.
The last part, and the most
important part-- and this
is why it's so
important that people
like Heather West and others,
and there is people, Pablo,
all these people are in DC.
If you've ever
interacted with them,
it's because you have to meet
with people face to face.
You have to talk directly to
other companies about things
that you may find to
be of common interest,
and then trade
associations, people
who can sort of,
like a union does,
aggregate all of
various companies
in a sector to say
things of real import.
There's a whole bunch of
other people we talked to.
To give you an example,
this is the way
that we-- two things we really
value at CDT are convenings
and expertise, so we'll
often bring people
together in a very closed door
meeting, Chatham House rules.
Or something we even call
stricter than Chatham House
rules, and that
means you can talk
about what people--
the Chatham House is
you can talk about what
someone said there,
but you can't attribute anything
said to any specific person.
The stricter than
Chatham House rules
is you can talk about
the meeting was about,
but you can't talk about
anyone, or any industry,
specifically said.
And so it gets kind of weird.
But we talked about-- recently,
we had a convening on hack
back.
This is the idea of
companies are getting
attacked constantly,
and they may
want to take some
measures to respond.
And how far can they go?
Right now, under the
law, not very far.
You can do pretty
much anything you
want inside your own network,
but the second it leaves
your network, there's
not a lot you can do.
And there's a really
good book that I
can refer you to
about this stuff.
It's brand new, and it gives
sort of a really neat framework
to think about it.
But the whole point
of that convening
was what are people
doing, what do
they want to do, how would
this be received by DC, what
are some of the risks
that can involved.
If you take down a
hospital in attacking back,
and it's in the middle
of nowhere China
or something like that,
that's going to be really bad,
and you don't want to have
the kind of collateral damage.
And that can happen because it's
very hard to attribute things
on the internet.
It's very hard to know
who you're actually
interacting with.
They could be coming through
a hospital to attack,
and you never even know.
OK, so let's get to
some of the cases here.
First thing I'm
going to talk about
is the FBI and
their quest to have
more backdoors into things.
So in 1994, there
was a law passed
called CALEA, the Communications
Assistance for Law Enforcement
Act, and this was essentially
the law enforcement community
realizing that people are moving
from regular landline phones,
that you could take two little
alligator clips to and listen
to what they're
talking about if you
get to the write little
wire loop somewhere.
There is increasingly
digital switching.
There is a whole bunch
of new technologies
that made it very hard
to do wiretapping,
and so they passed a
law that said anyone
who does telecommunications
has to build, and has to buy
and has to build
into these systems,
a way for us to
actually wiretap people.
And curiously
enough, that did not
apply to sort of the burgeoning
internet, at that time,
and the web, which
was about to be born,
and that's a very good
thing, in our opinion.
Now, fast forward about
2010, about 2010, the FBI
started to argue via
their general counsel,
a woman named
Valerie Caproni, who
I think now works for
Boeing, that they were,
quote, unquote, going dark.
And what they argued
is, geeze, people
aren't using-- it's not
just about the copper
wire and the alligator
clips anymore.
People are not even using
phones that much anymore.
They're talking in ways, to
each other, that don't even
include telecommunications
protocols at all.
For example, if you think
about web mail, like email,
you may start your day off at
your home answering some email.
You may go to a coffee shop
and answer some more email.
If they want to
wiretap you using
the signals on the
very end there,
they have to actually,
first of all,
have a relationship with your
internet service provider
to do that.
And if they're using Gmail,
they will get entirely encrypted
stuff because you guys use SSL.
But if they're using someone
else who doesn't do SSL,
but then they have
to figure out,
OK, well, that's the
coffee shop you went to.
Who's their ISP?
I need to wiretap
you there, too.
And so they're really
worried about people sort
of hopping around
so much that they
can't do it in a turnkey manner.
In fact, a number of
people have argued
sort of the opposite, that
now, in this day and age,
it's actually a golden
age of surveillance.
The more that we do every
day-- more and more,
what we do every day is mediated
by things that can record what
we're doing, and
there's so many signals
being passed around
that it's not
so hard to imagine
recording that stuff.
And this is actually
Peter Swire,
and [INAUDIBLE] Ahmad
wrote this for us.
It's a really neat,
wonderful piece just
to point to and
say, look, in fact,
it's not exactly this
going dark problem.
What we, in fact, have
is more and more people
collecting more and more
stuff about what we do.
Then about round 2010, we
started hearing grumblings
about something that
we're calling CALEA II,
and this is plugging
this loophole
in the original
wiretapping law that
would extend wiretapping
obligations to software itself.
And we think that is a
horrifically bad idea.
And some of these
proposals would basically
require you to
write software that
was born with a wiretap
capability in it, so born
wiretap capable.
And if you didn't do that,
they would come to you,
and you'd get these
escalating fine regimes.
And it's actually totally--
some of these things
were leaked in the press,
and they got pretty strange.
Like the Washington Post
claimed they would serve you
with this thing saying you
need to change your software
to build in this wiretap
capability, this backdoor
into it.
If you didn't do it in 90
days, you'd get a $10,000 fine,
and that $10,000 would be
doubled every day indefinitely.
[LAUGHTER]
JOE HALL: That's the kind
of reaction I like to hear.
You know, it doesn't
take very long
to get to the entire market
cap of most organizations,
or most businesses in
some small countries.
A couple of weeks is all you
need of that kind of thing
to totally wipe someone out.
So then the next week,
about a week or two later,
it was, oh, this is going
to be $25,000 a day,
and it's going to be additive.
And I'm like, OK,
at least then, i
can start seeing
you making a case
that this is just
a cost of business
if you're going to do
secure communications.
But in the end, we
really don't think
that there should
be any law that
outlaws purely encrypted
end-to-end communication
systems, which it sounds
like this would do,
sort of require you to
serve clear text to people.
So we've been hearing about
this, and we're like, OK,
what can we do here?
And this is one of the
key ways that we operate.
We organized an
expert report, so we
got a bunch of extremely
smart people together.
We wrote a sort
of draft, and said
what do you guys
think about this?
How can we make this better?
And it involved sort
of a curated list of 20
of the top cryptography,
computer security, and network
security experts in
the world, one of which
is sitting in this room, Susan.
But this is a really
interesting list of people,
and this is curated
in a way that it's not
sort of simply people that
everybody would recognize.
So there's people on
here that definitely
have cachet, so the Peter
Neumanns, Edward Feltens,
Phil Zimmerman who created PGP.
He was involved with this.
But they're sort of
young people and people
that keep a low profile.
So Eric [INAUDIBLE], who
now works in Mozilla.
Fred Schneider, very,
very smart professor
at Cornell, who was on the,
believe, the Air Force defense
or one of the defense
advisory boards,
so very top secret
cleared individual
who was willing to
make this argument.
Anyway, so a whole bunch
of really-- Matt Green,
who's probably one of
the most accomplished
and promising young
applied cryptographers.
Feel free to take issue
with any of this in the Q&A.
But our argument was
relatively simple.
We talked about a few things.
We said the architected
vulnerabilities,
what you're asking,
these back doors
just fundamentally
undermine security.
When you engage
in communications,
these are things
that are designed
to undermine your ability to
speak privately and securely
with someone, and
it's designed to do so
in a way that is undetectable,
which is fundamentally
a problem.
These things are backdoors.
These kinds of backdoors and
endpoint software and products,
are really difficult and messy.
So for example, if you do say,
OK, FBI tells me, via this law,
we have to build a backdoor
into what we're doing,
how do you manage that?
How do you manage
access to that?
If you get a valid law
enforcement request
from Iran or from
China, what do you do?
So you say, OK, well, we have
a business case that we're not
going to do that or whatever.
Or you get one from
a police officer
in a tiny town
somewhere in America,
and you may not be-- especially
if you're a mom and pop shop,
you may not have the capability
to sort of understand
what's going on
there or the desire
to think about those
kinds of things.
And this sort of
slam dunk argument,
it's always good to
have one of those,
is that this is just
not going to work.
If you put backdoors in
these products, a lot of them
are open source,
Chrome, Firefox.
You can see these things,
rip them out, open SSL.
The things that are
not open source,
you can have binary patches.
That's what a jailbreak is,
is a binary patch to something
to make it do something else.
And finally, you could
actually procure this stuff
into some country that doesn't
have a stupid law like that,
so it doesn't make any
sense to do any of this.
We took a small group of these
people, so Ed Felten, Bruce
Schneier, Eric [INAUDIBLE],
and Mike [INAUDIBLE],
a former student of
Matt Blaise who's
now a professor at
Georgetown, to the White House
and the Department of Commerce.
The Department of Commerce
was very much sort of-- it
felt like they wanted
ammo to try and shoot
these kinds of things down,
whereas in the White House,
it was very clear that
they were sort of listening
but not playing in other
cards or showing us anything.
They didn't really
make any commitments.
They didn't seem
to be very shocked.
I think this is
sort of something
they expected and heard before.
Now, the key part of
this, and something
that I have to emphasize,
is that this is only
the first part of the battle
against the FBI in terms
of backdoors.
It didn't deal with
centralized services.
Our argument was
all about endpoints,
and unfortunately, and sadly, if
you, as someone in the middle,
have clear text, if you
have access to the stuff,
you can be compelled
to give it over.
And so there's examples,
hush mail about 10 years ago.
Lavabit, most recently,
shut itself down rather than
give up 400,000 of its users
to, I believe, the FBI.
We're going to need help
making these arguments
about centralized services.
For example, how does lawful
intercept undermine security?
I need to be able to make
that argument sometime
in the future, not
anytime really soon.
But I think this underlines
that, especially at CDT,
and I think hopefully,
people in this room
agree, that you
can't tap everything.
Technically, there will be
something that you cannot
listen to.
I think that there's a
lot of interest these days
in the venture capital community
about end-to-end secure
communication tools
of various types.
There's just a ton
of action there,
and that was before Snowden.
That was a thing before Snowden.
It's definitely bigger, now.
And this may sound kind
of sci-fi, but it's true.
We will have things
you put in your head
to computationally
support cognition
at some point in the future.
Maybe it's farther away
than some people think,
but who knows.
It's going to happen.
That stuff should
not-- you should
have an enclave inside
your head that you
can keep your
secrets to yourself.
I mean, we need some sort of--
I don't know what we need.
We need something that
basically makes that happen.
So that was all in play,
and then Snowden happened.
So that was May 16 when we
wrote that, and then June 4 is
when Snowden happened.
And so to transition
into another case study,
the cryptapocalypse, and I have
to go a little bit faster here.
And what I mean by the
cryptapocalypse-- so
cryptography involves
math that is hard.
So math that you can do
easily in one direction,
but it's very hard to do
in the other direction,
like really hard, like billions
of years of computational power
hard.
This year has been,
since June, a real pain
in the butt for some of us
just because every week you
get this new revelation, and
we have to make sense of it.
We have to make sure that
we have a policy response,
we got a press responsible,
blah, blah, blah.
But for now, I'm going
to focus on two things.
I need to move a little
quicker than I thought,
but Bullrun and something
called MUSCULAR.
Bullrun is essentially
the NSA's program,
and the GCHQ, the
UK version of NSA,
the Government
Communications Headquarters.
It's not a very
descriptive title.
But they're using tricks,
as Bruce Schneier says,
to undermine security.
They are either stealing
or compelling people
to write certificates for
them, SSL certificates.
You can think of it
as stealing encryption
keys or compelling people
to give you the keys.
It seems like they're
planting moles in internet
and technology companies,
so someone in this room
may by paid by the
NSA in addition
to being paid by Google.
Who knows?
And we've seen some
companies actually
institute military
security protocols,
to where very sensitive
things are handled
by two people, and your hopeful
that not both those people are
a mole.
And they've been planning
backdoors and standards,
and when someone comes with a
set of source code to the NSA
and says please help us
evaluate this implementation
of a cryptography
product, they will say,
oh, here's a couple of things
we found that were problems.
Here's a couple of
vulnerabilities,
and they're also keeping some
for themselves to use later.
And MUSCULAR, you
may all know about.
They're up on your data
center traffic, apparently,
and they're using
the sort of lack
of constitutional oversight
in foreign countries
to tap that traffic.
Obama, at some point, realized
that this wasn't going to stop
and decided he'd put a
panel to study the thing
and tell him what he should do.
We were all bit
disappointed to see
that it was,
essentially, all law
professors and all
insiders, so everyone
had some sort of involvement
with the Obama administration.
Although, Peter Swire is one
of them, and Peter Swire,
if any of you know
him, is awesome.
He wrote that thing about the
golden age of surveillance.
Definitely a skeptic
about surveillance.
The CDT, Dan Auerback,
if you knew him.
I think he used to be a Googler.
And EFF, we basically
responded in a public comment
kind of forum, so not this is
an expert report that we're
going to put up here, but
this is sort of an argument
that we want to make that
a lot of people believe in.
And 47 people signed onto it.
You probably can't
read this, but there's
a lot of really
neat people here.
I'm going to bring
your attention.
We're trying to continue
to sort of bring
in a bunch of different
kinds of people,
so there are some--
Ross Anderson
and Stephen Farrell
are both UK based
security experts
of various types.
Joan Feigenbaum, we have some
sort of theoretical crypto kind
of people, people who do
sort of bigger thinking,
and a whole bunch of
scrappy activists.
Ash [INAUDIBLE], Runa
Sandvik from the Tor Project,
although they didn't list
that affiliation here.
Morgan Marquis-Boire,
who affiliation here
with Citizen Lab, but he is a
Googler, very, very smart guy.
We made the following
argument, which
is that if you're going
have a secret court that's
going to look at
technical topics,
you need that secret
court to have someone
with technical expertise on it
to evaluate the arguments that
are being made.
Not only that,
but we pointed out
how not having a
technical person
in the room for
this stuff resulted
in a massive overcollection of
surveillance data in the past,
specifically with
something called
MCTs, multi communications
transactions.
That's like they grabbed a Gmail
screen shot as it flies by,
and so it has a bunch of to
and from email traffic on it.
One of those may be
a foreign person,
which means they can keep
it, but all the rest aren't.
And they claim that it's
not technically possible
for them to sort
these things out,
which is bullshit because,
if you look at the JSON
structure for that, you
could very easily grab
just what you wanted.
And there's other things,
like call detail records,
which they're grabbing
all of our call detail
records every day in the US.
Apparently, at one point,
they include cell towers.
They don't now, they tell us.
I don't know how we're
supposed to know that for sure,
but at some point they did.
Because when the cops come
and ask a telecommunications
carrier for call detail
records, they typically
get the cell towers you
connected to when you made
calls.
That's very easy, and
increasingly easier,
to use to pinpoint your
location throughout the day.
We talked about
wholesale attacks.
These are non targeted.
You're weakening
everyone's security.
But I think the most important
argument that we made,
that got Ross Anderson and
Stephen Farrell on-- this
is something that we're
going to be making
a lot more noise
about very soon.
--is that the US's commitments
to civil liberties and privacy
really demand that we treat non
US persons' data with respect.
We can't just sort of say,
oh, they're foreigners.
We can do anything
we want to them.
That is just totally offensive.
It's especially
offensive to anyone
who runs a global
internet business.
Part of these
revelations revealed
that the NSA is doing
some things that-- it's
kind of hard to tell
exactly what they're doing,
but it seems to be clear
that they planted a backdoor,
that there may be a backdoor--
we can't know for sure.
--in this particular
thing called DUAL_EC_DRBG.
It's a random number generator.
In cryptography we
have to generate
a lot of random
numbers very quickly.
You can't just use dice.
It would take you forever,
and it would not be fun.
But NIST actually, when
they heard about this,
thought long and hard about it
for a few days, and then said
please don't use this thing.
We think there's
a problem with it.
If you think there's a
problem with it, let us know.
Please don't use this thing.
And then you saw
RSA security, which
makes a lot of libraries
for cryptography products,
issue a product recall.
The first product
recall I know of,
and I'd love to be
proven different, where
it was essentially
someone recalling
a product because their own
government had sort of hacked
their stuff.
That was not a
good thing to see.
The fact that they had
been accused of or had,
or it was unclear that they'd
inserted a backdoor in this one
random number
generator caused people
to start looking
around other things,
and this curious case
of SHA-3 came around.
SHA-3 is a hash
standard, something
used in the
cryptographic hashes.
This is a five year
competition to replace SHA-1.
SHA-1 is based on this
way of doing hashes that
had been attacked,
and was basically
everyone thought that, at some
point, it will fall entirely,
and you won't be able to use
any of the stuff anymore.
They won the competition
in October of 2012,
this is one called Keccak.
It's a really fascinating thing.
I can talk about more
if you hear about it.
It turns out it was modified,
after the competition,
by NIST before it wrote it up
into a long, boring document
that says if you're going to
build something that does this,
here's how you do it.
And a lot of people are like
why did you modify that?
Why did you reduce
the security of it?
And a number of
different arguments.
So when I heard about
this, first of all,
I tried to make sense
of it, and so I wrote up
a little blog post
that basically
said what the heck is
going on with SHA-3.
And I figured the cryptographic
community isn't that big.
Nerds who care about this,
there's not that many of them.
I'm going to put this up.
It totally took our server down.
I don't know what it was.
Part of the problem is,
because of who we are,
we don't drop
cookies, and we don't
drop locally stored
objects, which
means we can't use things like
Cloudflare to sort of-- anyway,
I could talk more about that.
But anyway, so it brought
our thing to its knees,
and we're like, oh, geeze,
people care about this.
I met with the White House, two
people at the White House, Tim
Polk and R. Schwartz,
and [INAUDIBLE]
really concerned about this.
Why don't you just
standardize the thing
that won the competition?
It looks bad if you don't.
Turns out, that resonated,
and in fact, SHA-3
is now going to be
standardized, and it's
as won in the competition form.
It's going to have all the
strong secure-- I mean,
this is like pre-image collision
on two to the 500-- I mean,
it's just so enormously huge.
It'll probably be a very long
time before anyone actually
cracks it, but the whole point
was have a really strong one
for people who do really
crazy things like elections
or certain kinds of
mixed [INAUDIBLE].
You need a whole lot of
collision resistance.
Anyway, but NIST is
also doing some review
of their entire cryptographic
standards suite.
Let's talk about drones.
[LAUGHTER]
JOE HALL: So drones are really
interesting because it's
sort of a novel technology.
It's not like
something before it.
It's really new in DC, and I'll
try and be really quick here.
They have a whole
lot of promise.
100% of crop dusting
is done in Japan
with drones, unmanned
aircraft, and the whole point
is crop dusting is
extremely dangerous.
You often have wind
breaks at the end.
You're really low, and if you
don't pull up quick enough,
you hit a bunch of
trees, and you die.
And it's horrible.
It's useful for a
whole bunch of things.
There is a very
serious potential
for abuse with unmanned
systems, especially
these kinds of systems.
They're really tiny.
You often hear
before you seem them.
They're very, very
cheap, so right now, you
can get one for about $300,
a quadracopter from Parrot.
There are no humans on board,
and that's a good thing,
but it means that they can
go places that planes can't.
So it can go between
buildings, and it
can do things that
planes can't do.
It can handle crazy G-Forces.
Some of these things
can stay aloft
for many, many days,
weeks in some cases.
These are gas powered,
obvious, not battery powered.
And they're going to, very soon,
have all types of surveillance
packages that manned
aircraft have.
Gigapixel cameras, so being able
to get centimeter resolution
in a place like Manhattan
can be very useful
for a variety of things.
LiDAR, laser kinds
of things, can
see through foliage,
an image what's
behind sort of disuse
kinds of barriers.
Synthetic aperture radar
could see through your drapes
at home, and it can tell if
something in your front lawn
hasn't move a couple centimeters
and things like that.
And these aren't things that
people really understand,
or we should understand or
should begin to understand.
The FAA has to integrate drones
into the national air space
by 2015, and they're going
through a regulatory process
to do that.
We're really thinking a lot
about privacy and safety
for drones.
You know, how do other aircraft
know what's around them?
If you ever flown aircraft,
birds are real problem.
Well, think of these as
metal and plastic birds
that are flying around
that you might smack into.
And how do people
in their backyard
get an idea of what's
in the sky above them.
We imagined pretty
simple analogy.
For vehicles, some of this
stuff works with just a license
plate.
License plates aren't
there just for the cops.
It's for you, too.
Someone does something, or
someone left their lights on,
there's a whole bunch
of uses for sort
of a meat space
cookie for vehicles.
And planes have
something similar
in terms of an N-number on
their fuselage or their tail.
So I thought what about a
license plate for drones?
Well, an N-number is
way too damn tiny.
You'd need a telescope to
be able to visualize that,
and that's not going to work.
So what about a radio
frequency license plate?
What if you broadcast
an identifier?
And so I wrote this
thing that's kind of-- I
hadn't thought about this much.
I don't know anything
about flight regulations.
We got a lot of feedback,
and they clued us
into this thing called
ADS-B Out, automatic
dependent surveillance,
mode B out.
This is, essentially, a radio
frequency standard required
by the FAA for all
aircraft by 2020.
It broadcasts an identifier,
position, velocity,
altitude every couple
seconds, and it's
used on manned aircraft to sort
of replace-- when you do radar,
you get an echo back
from every sweep,
and you have to extrapolate
where the plane's going,
how fast it's going,
where it currently is,
and you have a very big
error radius on that value.
If it knows where it is, and
it tells people where it is,
and it's a very
precise type of thing,
you can actually reduce that
error radius and pack planes
in for landing a
whole lot quicker.
This is sort of how it works.
The planes have very
fine GPS, or GLONASS,
the Russian version of GPS.
And then they
broadcast this stuff,
and other planes can see them,
and ground based receivers
can see them, too.
We basically said,
OK, FAA, you need
to have a registry
that has who owns--
UAS is another word for drone.
Ask me why later.
You need to talk about
what kind of thing this is.
What kind of airframe type?
What weight does it have?
What's it's wingspan?
How big is it?
And then it needs to have
a data collection statement
that shows here's all the
stuff that we want to do.
Here's what we're
going to collect.
going to share it for.
Here's how long we're
going to keep it.
Here's someone to talk
to if you get upset.
And you should issue something
called a Mode S hex code, which
is the thing you broadcast
on your airplane.
It's a 24-bit identifier.
And then a U-number,
sort of like a N-number,
something that's human friendly.
You can think of those IP
address and domain name
if you want to.
We said everyone should have
to broadcast this thing,
but it's unclear if it should
have to be from the airframe
or from the ground.
And the whole idea here is
that both people in aircraft
and people on the ground
can, in real time,
see what drones are doing.
And the FAA-- or you
could have a Google Drone
that sort of showed where all
the drones were in a given
area.
In fact, you can buy
stuff that does this now
because some companies already
have their planes outfitted
to the 2020 standard,
so you can go, for $900,
buy this little antenna
that hooks up to your iPad.
For some reason, they'll
only work with iPads.
Not sure why.
Maybe they just want to
support one platform.
Here's another one from
Garmin, a little bit cheaper.
You can use these in planes.
Maybe that's why, because a
lot of the flight plan software
is iPad based.
Oops, since we said this,
and essentially said that,
the FAA responded and
said, oh, we don't care,
which is too bad.
But there's been a lot of
other interest in this,
and I think the FAA may
actually mandate this.
There are a lot
of complications.
If you want to have
these things on aircraft,
you need a flight certified
GPS, which is really expensive.
And you have to
have a transponder.
So this is what
these things look
like they have a
human interface, which
you don't need for a drone.
And that hardware box is about
the size of the pack of cards,
so it's not that big.
And you probably
can't read this,
but I actually wrote these
guys at Trig Avionics that
make that things, and it's like,
hey, how much does this cost?
And said, you know,
we're actually
outfitting these
things on drones
that have to operate in airspace
that require this right now.
It's about $6,000, so if you
have a $300 drone, in order
to play, maybe you have to
spend six grand to get it up.
Maybe that's OK.
Maybe it raises the
barrier high enough
to where not everyone
will have one.
I don't know.
Anyway, that's it.
Sorry, I went way over.
[APPLAUSE]